[musique]
Et c’est répandu, c’est-à-dire qu’il ne s’arrête pas, c’est-à-dire qu’il se propage facilement.
La plupart d'entre eux lui sont enlevés, ce qui signifie qu'ils sont répartis partout
Facilement, et quand j'ai commencé à le prendre, c'est exact
Ça me donne de l'énergie, mais au final, je veux dire
Tu utilises des astuces puissantes pour moi
Cela signifie que la fin, si elle est enregistrée, c'est la mort, parce que c'est notre humiliation.
C'est le passe-temps d'un jeune homme, pas seulement je l'ai vu de tes yeux
Surtout des jeunes
C'est la fin, s'il est enregistré que Fahna meurt.
Personne ne veut mourir lui-même et je ne veux pas être emprisonné
Quelqu'un retourne à sa vie et vit dans un état du monde
[musique]
Durant cette période, dix personnes ont été arrêtées
Des milliers de personnes sont accusées de délits liés à la drogue et des quantités saisies
Grand, environ 500 kilogrammes de matériau
Des stupéfiants de divers types ont été saisis et environ
Dix millions de pilules narcotiques Captagon
Dans le gouvernorat de Bagdad et dans d'autres gouvernorats
[musique]